ich möchte Ihnen eine Frage geben von
Michael Brocks aus Nortorf ganz oben in
Schleswig-Holstein und der fragt sich
immer warum können oder müssen Schüler
ohne Schulabschluss und als Analphabeten
die Schule verlassen das ist mir völlig
unverständlich schreibt der Box können
sie es ihm erklären nein wir haben das
Recht auf Bildung und wir haben auch das
Versprechen in unserer Gesellschaft dass
wenn jemand sich anstrengt er mit seiner
eigenen Leistung was erreichen kann und
deswegen ist ja auch das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil das war
im Zusammenhang mit Corona aber ganz
klar das Recht auf Bildung aber als
Analphabet ehrlich gesagt versteh ich
das auch nicht es gibt immer mehr an
Alphabeten die durch ihre Schulzeit
durch marschieren wie wie kann das gehen
ja also wir haben natürlich eine
alphabetenquote wie viel jetzt genau
eine Schule verlassen mit wirklich an
alphabetismus da müsste man
wahrscheinlich noch mal Zahlen erheben
aber nichtsdestotrotz auch schon ohne
Schulabschluss also ich meine
Analphabetismus da machen wir auch viel
Alpha Dekade
niedrigschwellig die Leute überhaupt zu
erreichen ja ähm weil das ist für die ja
auch schwierige überhaupt sich zu äußern
bzw
haben haben eine Welt die sie überhaupt
nachvollziehen können die sie verstehen
können warum in Deutschland Menschen
ohne Schulabschluss ohne lesen und
schreiben zu können von der Schule
kommen
es darf nicht passieren es darf einfach
nicht passieren verstehen können Sie das
auch nicht ne nein wie gesagt wie viel
jetzt wirklich dann gar mit so wenig
Möglichkeiten hinterher das Leben selbst
bestimmt zu gehen die Schule verlassen
das müsste man noch mal nachvollziehen
aber ohne Abschluss ist halt einfach
immens schwer da ist hinterher auch die
Frage wie kann ich überhaupt ein
Berufsweg einschlagen und deswegen
müssen wir die Zahl reduzieren deswegen
sagen wir als Bund ja auch da wollen wir
mit unterstützen damit die Grundlagen
damit sich da was ändert und vor allen
Dingen müssen wir gucken was passiert
auch mit denen bei denen das jetzt schon
der Fall ist weil das sind ja 630.000
Menschen in unserem Land und die
brauchen wir und vor allem die brauchen
auch perspektion 630.000 ja die Zahlen
muss man sich ja noch mal vergewährt wer
gegenwärtigen das ist ja wirklich völlig
unverständlich so woher brauchst das
schreibt passiert sowas auch wegen
Schluffi Unterricht wie man nennen würde
dass also die These würde ich jetzt das
ist eine These die nicht belegt ist also
das würde ich so würde ich mich nicht
anschließen aber wir dürfen nicht weg
gucken wo die jungen Menschen aber das
ist tatsächlich ein Thema das ganz viele
unserer Leser beschäftigt wird sagen die
häufigste Frage kommt dazu Disziplin
Ordnung nachhalten im Unterricht
wirklich nachfragen sind die
Hausaufgaben gemacht die Hefte angucken
die Schrift sich angucken ob die
ordentlich ist also noch mal deswegen
die Frage liegt es auch am
schluffiunterricht heute also festhalten
muss man lernen ist keine
Körperverletzung die kann man
spielerisch sein die kann auch mal durch
Üben sein das kann ganz unterschiedlich
aussehen wichtig ist dass eben nicht
weggeguckt wird wenn die Leistung nicht
da sind und auch das dass die Kompetenz
nicht da ist und ähm wie gesagt das kann
eine Kombination aus ganz verschiedenen
Sachen sein aber wir müssen auch stolz
sein auf Leistung die junge Menschen
bringen
und Schülerinnen in der Breite nicht
absolut absolut wir fördern übrigens
auch wir wollen ja mit dem
startchancenprogramm gerade da wo es
besonders schwierig ist fördern aber wir
haben auch ein Programm das gerade die
Leistung starken Schülerinnen und
Schüler die noch mal eine ganz besondere
Ansprache brauchen eben auch
Unterstützung haben wir brauchen noch
mal zurück zusätzlich zugehen Unterricht
noch im Moment bleiben und sie müsste
jetzt das Wort ja gar nicht so eigen
machen aber ich nenne ihn Beispiel jetzt
beginnen gerade in diesen Tagen ganz
vielen Bundesländern die Sommerferien
Unterricht ist da seit 14 Tagen seit 21
Tagen weitgehend nicht mehr da sind die
Noten da sind die Klausuren weitgehend
geschrieben da findet im Grunde keinen
Unterricht mehr statt ein bisschen Filme
gucken noch hier noch mal Ausflug hier
noch mal ein Sommerfest oder Sportfest
warum ist das so
also erstmal möchte ich sagen wir wollen
ja nicht alle über einen Kamm scheren
das wirklich ich habe gerne ganz tolle
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer ich lerne sie
werden solche Beispiele kennen ich
glaube das müssen wir auch mal der Ferne
Cyber sagen damit sich nicht so der
Eindruck verfestigt aber natürlich haben
wir ja auch Personalmangel also es ist
ja oft die Stunden die nicht mehr
gehalten werden können das verstärkt
natürlich noch mal die Belastung jedes
einzelnen der für den Klassen steht und
insofern ist das eigentlich ein Grund
der Lehrer dabei dann beim Filme gucken
beim Ausflug machen beim Sportfest beim
Sommerfest sind ja Lehrer dabei da
herrschte in dem Moment anscheinend gar
keinen Mangel das heißt wenn ich in dem
Moment Lehrer bin dann muss doch den
Anspruch haben bis zum Schluss
durchzuziehen mit Spaß den Kindern noch
was beizubringen selbst wenn sich das in
der Note nicht mehr auswirkt das scheint
ja die Ursache zu sein also ist man
leistungsbereit hat man Interesse
wirklich an den Kindern
also wir sehen wir sehen ja auch bei den
vielen bei den vielen Erfahrungswerten
die sich zusammenbringen dass schon die
Frage ist auch in Deutschland sind wir
ja noch das letzte Land das
Vorbereitungszeit von leeren und Lehrern
nicht als Arbeitszeit in vollem Maße
ansieht also bei uns im Gegensatz zu
anderen Ländern die auch deutlich besser
abschneiden im Ranking hat der Lehrer
und die Lehrerin auch viel mehr
Möglichkeiten noch über das hinaus was
an Unterrichtsstunden wirklich vor der
Klasse zu leisten ist dass das als
Arbeitszeit gezählt wird und ich glaube
das ist etwas den muss man sich
anschauen weil dieses Bild das alle
Lehrer eben ein faul sind und nichts
arbeiten wollen das stimmt nicht aber
die versuchen als in anderen Ländern wir
haben noch dieses deputationsmodell
nennt sich das das im Prinzip
Leistungskontrolle sozusagen für die
Lehrer dadurch
geben dass sie ihre Arbeit auch wirklich
so ausfüllen können wie sie das möchten
und wie wir sie auch von ihnen erwarten
wenn sie nicht in Zeiten des Lehr
mangels das bedeutet ja es wird weniger
unterrichtet
da werden wir heute eine Wette ein
eingehen das werden sie leider auch wenn
wir auf die Demografie gucken in den
nächsten Jahren nicht lösen das heißt
darin liegt nicht die Lösung in dem was
sie gerade sagen das ist natürlich
brauchen wir mehr Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
weil das immer noch der Mensch
entscheidend
in den nächsten Jahren ja es werden
jetzt wir haben ja die
zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre
geschafft das heißt wir geben mehr
Grundfinanzierung den Ländern für die
Hochschulen und dort haben sich auch
schon viele Länder selbst verpflichtet
zu sagen wir wollen mehr Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer ausbilden und das ist auch
richtig dann haben wir schon darüber
gesprochen wie kriegen wir den
Lehrerinnen und Lehrerberuf attraktiv
und dann müssen wir auch noch gucken wie
können wir eigentlich Schule gestalten
als Ökosystem die kann man es auch
öffnen die kann man auch außer
schulische Lernen Orte wie kann ich auch
mal mit Praktika arbeiten was nicht sagt
dass wir nicht den grundständigen
Unterricht brauchen aber ich glaube wir
müssen Schule neu denken dann damit wir
eben diese die vielen Themen die jetzt
auf die Schule einwirken auch lösen
können ich will beim Thema Leistung noch
mal bleiben weil das so sehr unsere
leserum treibt Johanna Kaub aus
Düsseldorf schreibt und die war Lehrerin
ganz lange nämlich hat auch nach ihrem
Renteneintritt noch immer wieder an der
Schule ausgeholfen dort an der bringt
brennpunktschule wie sie schreibt und
sie sagt Schule muss doch wieder
Leistung einfordern die Unis die
beklagen auch den schlechten
Wissensstand der Studenten schreibt sie
es muss viele reformiert werden aber
nicht weich gespült werden das ist
richtig weil wenn man Probleme zudeckt
dann kommen Sie später das heißt wenn
ich nichts lerne das wird sich später
irgendwann zeigen und insofern ist ganz
klar ich persönlich bin auch nicht für
die Abschaffung der Noten das ist nicht
allein glücklich machen aber alleine mal
zu zeigen wo stehe ich und das auch
offen zu adressieren also wegschauen hat
noch nie geholfen und deswegen Leistung
ist auch keine Charakterschwäche sondern
ist schön und deswegen sollte Leistung
auch anerkannt toleriert und vor allen
Dingen auch die richtigen Anreize
gesetzt sie hat möglicherweise im Kopf
solche Dinge wie in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern eine matte Abi
Klausur bei der es anschließend hieß
dann die Zeit zu scher geworden hat der
Mathe Abi Jahrgang sehr schlecht
abgeschnitten also wurden alle eine Note
raufgestuft anschließend dort in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist das sie sind
FDP dem Leistungsprinzip folgen also ich
mache hier Verträge zu lassen von
Dritten weil dafür ja die Länder
zuständig sind auch für die
Schulaufsicht zuständig sind aber
persönlich kann ich sagen nein weil man
damit niemanden hilft Corona war eine
ganz besonders schwierige Zeit dass man
da gesagt hat wir wollen nicht dass er
jetzt auch noch Jahre verliert das ist
was ganz Spezielles da haben wir auch
viel zu lange die Schulen geschlossen
aber unseren Kindern unheimlich viel
abverlangt aber dauerhaft löst das nicht
das dass wir setzen wir darüber sprechen
dass wir auch andere andere Fähigkeiten
in Zukunft brauchen aber natürlich muss
ich lesen rechnen und schreiben können
und muss auch die Anspruch also erfüllen
und ehrlich gesagt Länder in denen ja
auch ähm das Bildungssystem gut
abschneidet die haben eben auch diese
Vergleichbarkeit von Abschlüssen
noch ein ein Zuschrift dazu kommt von
Felix Staffen und er arbeitet in der
Kita also der merkt dass das mit dem
Leistungsprinzip schon in der Kita
eigentlich an manchen Stellen vorhanden
sein müsste gibt es ja auch
lernstandsmessungen und so weiter vor
allen Dingen im Vorschuljahr da ist er
auch tätig und der schreibt moderne
Kuschelpädagogik ist ein großer Faktor
für Schwierigkeiten ich sehe wie
inzwischen viele Fachkräfte lasch
erziehen und alles laufen lassen wenn
die Kinder keine Lust auf Angebote haben
na dann halt nicht ich arbeite im
Vorschulbereich einer Kita und sehe
Werder bei den Schuluntersuchung dann
also wenn es drauf ankommt
durchgewunken wird das ist teilweise
sehr schwierig zu ertragen schreibt der
Staffel schon zu den Kitas wie gesagt
ich glaube man tut den Kindern keinen
Gefallen noch mal es geht jetzt nicht um
das Drill Inspektoren ständig unsere
Kinder es kann auch sehr spielerisch
sein aber jetzt ist ja Urlaubszeit viele
fahren in Urlaub haben sie immer Lust
auf dem Berg drauf zu wandern aber wenn
sie dann da oben sind und zwischendrin
haben
da schaffe ich das dann ist man
unheimlich stolz also sich auch
anzustrengen und dann auch dieses
Erfolgserlebnis haben und weil das kann
jedes Kind und deswegen sollten das ihm
auch nicht nehmen